a Ukrainian fighter jet swoops over the
city of sloviansk it's part of the
government effort to oust pro-russian
separatists in the east of the country
authorities in Kiev say they have
regained control of several areas no
she's brewing a sheila zass asia our
military units have removed separatists
from the southern and western parts of
donetsk as well as areas north of
luhansk the new spear which is the exact
muchos demo meanwhile the fate of the
four OSCE members kidnapped by rebels in
Donetsk on Monday remains unclear the
security organization has not confirmed
reports of their release it said on
Facebook that another of its teams is
now missing the group of five haven't
been heard from since Thursday when they
were stomped by gunmen in an area north
of Luhansk in a television interview US
Secretary of State John Kerry reiterated
his call on Russia to do more to
stabilize the situation are moving back
towards of us he's demanding a full
withdrawal of Russian troops from the
Ukrainian border he's also expressed
concern over reports of chechen
militants joining the fight this is
gonna respect there is evidence of
Russians crossing over trained personnel
from Chechnya trained in Russia who've
come across to stir things up to engage
in fighting reports of Chechen gunmen
spilling into eastern Ukraine are
fueling fears that the conflict could
attract more fighters from unstable
areas of the former Soviet Union
you